yeah welcome to this video playing
Generalissimo's that's Grand Master
Ralph Mahmoud off from Azerbaijan I'm
pretty sure about that but I have to
check out yep hmm ok so is normally a
king's indian guy here we go ok I have a
very safe line against the things in
there that I can try let's see what is
to what is doing here ok maybe it takes
I don't know what is playing if he goes
knight c6 yeah I'm playing this this
delayed exchange so it's not a very
aggressive line but it's a pretty decent
line if you want to save game and he's a
very good tactician so why not this is
not necessarily meant to play for a draw
don't don't be don't think that
necessarily this is just very safe and
in some cases white can even play for a
slight edge let's see what happens here
I hope I'm not confusing things but I
think this is the way it is played I've
looked at this quite a quite a while ago
yeah look see one is the idea of course
let's go with them or the sea pawn
in some cases some a black has to be
yeah a bit cautious that is not even
getting into a slightly worse position
so okay he's just giving up that pawn
mmm okay you might have slight
compensation but really I'm going to
take it it is some never going to be a
young completely satisfactory for black
let's see how I'm playing that though
and maybe here and then see how can how
i can how i can now advance my key
inside somethin with g3 probably g3
Bishop g2 f1 yeah I really wonder about
that sacrifice had still somewhat
surprising decision the opposite colored
bishops however make it difficult I mean
he has definite chances of her for
holding that due to that fact so can I
get my Bishop to e6 or something that
would be really nice okay so now he
allows that and I'm going to go for that
he's got h5 coming but i think it's it's
useful to have the bishop on f5 not sure
what's better let's go here yeah okay i
can go g4 for the complete block but
it's difficult to see how to how to win
then that's difficult to see anyway so
let's see how can i can i do that
if he takes I might have aged 44 getting
a passed pawn so I don't think he wants
to take on g3 necessarily okay it does
interesting
okay so i'm getting a getting itch for
in king of three first and h4
maybe I can get this and then H for me
not that each for in itself does we know
anything but I get it's something it's
something at least yeah that's an
interesting point should I an evergage
we can take em yeah I wonder if i should
go age 5 or not maybe this one a try for
not interesting really a cheeky will
take a chip a guru cash to you take edge
form yeah okay I'm getting I'm getting
the passer that's not not bad though um
how to do that doubling their doesn't
help much so probably supported with g4
and then try to to play on the queenside
which is admittedly rather blocked so
let's see how to do that
can try I mean 11 idea is pinned playing
for a sacrifice on f6 something that I
can try one f4c threatening to take on
e6 here I don't know
maybe I wonder really one know what the
best way to do this is also be four
comes into consideration always actually
doing something time warning
yeah we have to get rid of that porn no
question and so it's it's it's a very
good position for white IAM probably
winning
a couple of ideas if the root trait is
winning with the deep on okay so let's
push that jacket looked in to check but
a hefty 7 coming up sinking c6 rugby 6
unfortunately I know it's not able to
play that move threatening luke t five
maybe now it's difficult only 30 seconds
check
check
check check 20 seconds
check-check me now ok I just killed
myself at the time that was it was a bit
of a joke this game three honest he just
killed himself the whole time and I I
just was too slow and yeah this is just
a total win jack so let's just see what
i could have done d 6 yeah Luke c6 is
better it seems sad it's a bit difficult
you have to still be precise iam Roxy
six it's much stronger oh that's it
listen we can he gets no move yet yes no
move him simply like this am and it's
all jack yeah that point sacrifice is
just I don't know which is silly is just
much worse and can hope to to somehow
hold on but this is also just mad taking
1g3 giving me the H porn it was
necessary at all so that's a bit of a
shame because he really played a
terribly bad game hey I'm sorry I mean
you have to be honest about that he can
be to 650 and feed or whatever he wants
but this was a crap game Jim the only
thing is I'm down a minute and he has a
ton of checks so check I even even that
should be a win at still plus two and
now taking what didn't I take here
taking us just just the total win 87 be
three
and over yeah sometimes I don't
understand what I'm doing thats that's
just very simple but that wins as well
t7 Andrew t5 is winning why didn't I do
that I don't know yeah I don't know that
was just totally total idiocy by me why
not rookie five I've got 40 seconds on
the clock and check Chad's it's still
winning let's even made computer season
made already after worked if I what am I
doing here yeah and again Rock t5 why
dont they play rook t5 ah l always
painful yeah they really play completely
complete Blancas chess and then you
don't see stuff like I mean I don't know
why don't I playbook t5 it's kind of
strange check last thing is it's still
winning it's still it's still totally
winning check check yeah here
unfortunately i'm lost to his room mate
on a eight and the rookies hanging but
by now everybody was down on time yeah I
know check sometimes it's hard to
explain what I'm doing them so when
rookie five is like the easiest move
ever it just promotes the palm what am i
doing yes sorry for the ranting but it's
always it's super painful to lose a game
against someone hated 2700 in the pool
who really played terribly bad and you
can win with such simple I mean more
than simple moves
and for some reason I don't play it this
is kind of weird anyway thanks for
watching